we gotta jump to this next a bit ya know
so this is the the Harper's letter that
was written and I want to give a [ __ ]
shout out to Bridget Fennessy who
tweeted to everyone who signed this
letter
welcome to the alt-right and I laughed
very much when I saw that excellent
tweet Bridget because this is a letter
on justice and open debate which
basically says cancel culture bed free
speech good and it was signed by a
hundred and fifty or so people well and
it includes a lot of people who are like
lefties who have actually tried engaging
in canceled culture it's fun kind of
funny well they're maybe they're
realizing just how bad things are but
special shout-out to people like Nick
Christakis Noam Chomsky didn't Elon Musk
say like eff Chomsky something he sure
did he doesn't not like Tomsky well I've
heard some I've heard some of Chomsky's
speeches over the past couple days like
Chomsky I've been looking into it and he
defends free speech heartily and he also
condemned the violence from antiva okay
I'm a man he has some crazy ideas he
certainly does enough about him but all
I know is that he there's a video I'm
still doing it there's a video I posted
from like the 70s or 80s or something
where he said straight up
I will legally defend a person I that I
use I abhor yeah if I'm defending their
free speech and people were yelling at
him for it I know saying that basically
by saying the speech is acceptable it's
a favorable view of their speech and
he's like no absolutely right to
expression must be distinct distinct
from so mad props we also got you know
and he said something that stuck with me
he said you're on two sides you either
agree with free speech as a whole or you
only agree with speech that you rang you
agree with there's no no difference or
there's nothing else it's either one or
the other period you know you know job
like man he's got a good point there you
know he used to be like the left-wing
Pope really I'm being very figured like
exaggerated but people on the Left held
him up as like the dude and so when anti
first started doing all this violence
people emailed Chomsky mmm-hmm and they
said how do you feel about this and he
said something I'm gonna try I'm gonna
try to get the köppen up I'm
paraphrasing when we entered the arena
of violence the most brutal guy wins
and that is not us and he was right you
know case in point the video of that
proud boy winding up the shot and then
boom and the guy goes flying yeah so
they were not anti foe but they like the
the right is restrained and doesn't want
to engage in violence so an tyfa is just
running amok and the cops aren't doing
anything about it
but so they so he's condemned and if his
violence
he said it's it's not a good idea he's
defended free speech he's also got a
bunch of really crazy far left the ideas
that's fine yeah I don't I don't care
like whatever your your your your views
are whatever you want to you live your
life as long as you're not violating the
rights of other people as long as your
your you're honest and truthful
respectful nonviolent then you can be a
communist so as long as so long as you
like I will sit down and have an
excellent debate with a communist as
long as they don't agree that they can
try and swing a punch at me because I
don't agree with them right like anti
fought now they're out of the question
but some commie wants to not have a
debate 100% let's have a debate disagree
I disagree but here's the best part
let's get to it
Matthew Iglesias oh yes Matthew Iglesias
is a co-founder of voxcom a progressive
media outlet designed to explain the
news which eventually just devolved into
left-wing rage bait and while I I want
to say that Matthew is not the worst
heat worst he called Donald Trump a
moderate and Fox is the snooty elitist
of the far left not the extreme reing of
the far left yeah I still think they're
responsible for a lot of the stuff
that's going on but something kind of
well i ron't nut maybe not ironic but
what's the word I'm thinking of let's
just say these way to explain it is you
reap what you sow no I mean kind of so
this is a letter written by some crits
the it's the critic at large I believe
for Vox Emily vanderwerff who I'll just
paraphrase wrote a letter saying I sent
a version of this to the editors of Vox
I've redacted some bits that are
internal to Vox and shouldn't be aired
publicly basically saying that it is a
privileged position for Matthew Iglesias
to be signing this letter and talking
about free speech because he doesn't
recognize how you know his privilege and
it negatively impacts marginalized
people notably that some of the people
who have signed this have
have-have anti-trans opinions and by
joining in with them it empowers them
and their positions and that puts them
at risk
I see JK Rowling's name rather oh
definitely and that's probably one of
the people that she was referring to
mm-hmm well Matthew Iglesias was then
let me at let me jump over here here we
go this is from Noam Blum he says if you
had any doubts that Iglesias was shut
down by his bosses after signing this
letter this from yesterday Matthew
Iglesias tweeted I have committed to not
doing contentious stuff on Twitter
anymore so I seriously can't comment on
this and would appreciate being taken
out of the thread hmm he has committed
to not doing this - who in - why
well we then have this from Ezra Klein
Ezra said a lot of debates that sell
themselves as being about free speech
are actually about power and there's a
lot of power in being able to claim and
hold the mantle of free speech defender
Ezra Klein is another co-founder of Vox
okay Matthew Iglesias said should I
reply to this - they concrete example or
stick to my commitments to you what have
we learned from these tweets somebody
who works at Vox wrote a letter saying
he was putting trans people at risk that
opens the door to discrimination
lawsuits by someone who can say my boss
signed a letter with transphobes
and and that proves he has a negative
view and so everything he did against me
was based on that discrimination and
that's the argument they could try and
make Matthew Iglesias says he made a
commitment to as recline and what was
that commitment that he will not speak
on contentious issues he's cancelled
that's it
goodbye himself he signed a letter to
defend defend cancel culture someone at
his company sent a letter in that was
properly worded and not overly
threatening and now he has had a
conversation with Ezra where he can not
comment anymore and here's the best part
as reclines comment about debates on
free speech is specifically targeting
Matthew Iglesias what have we learned
Matthew as the co-founder of Vox you are
no longer allowed to address your fellow
co-founders and co-workers when they
insult mock or criticize you and that's
what you that's the world you've built
yep so
I have to ask so a lot of times I talk
about how the left is really projecting
when they say that the right is doing
something wrong I think this is a
classic example of them projecting we're
gonna cancel you we're gonna talk to
your boss because this is exactly what
has just happened to Matthew and I think
that's what he's afraid of and I think
that's what people like him have tried
to do in the past we're gonna get two
cancelled you're fired you can't speak
he has done this I think that people on
the left not yeah yeah not as far as I
know but I think it's just productive
rejection just classic protection you
know that's what I came up with I
mentioned this the other day that guy
who was saying to me you're first
against the wall I'm in fact I'm gonna
call your I'm gonna call those who
employ you yes somebody somebody tweeted
this out I don't know who it was it was
a really good point and they said we
need canceled culture herd immunity
which means we need more people to be
canceled yeah there have been I could
see it but I mean I don't know it's
ridiculous what do you mean well yeah
you know the argument that if if
everyone gets canceled no one is if only
if only 50% of people are canceled and
canceled culture stops working
hmm okay so that's that's the idea herd
immunity yeah her so eventually so so
here's the hope to be less pessimistic
as I think the wind network is very
promising
it is a decentralized network of reddit
forums that have no boss yep no one
person who can just ban you that's
that's that's amazing
yes locals is another version of this
from Dave Rubens project another Dave
can't ban anybody I wasn't gonna start
streaming games on Twitch but I'm not
going anywhere close to twitch no way no
way I'm not touching that the feta verse
is a really interesting concept that
just hasn't gained traction what's up it
is a protocol kind of like what's these
way to explain it it would be like if
you gave people your math and address
and then it's subscribing to your
newsletter so it's a Twitter
that's decentralized and there are
different servers so Mastodon was was I
think is the biggest but it's very far
left they ban everything
they banned Wil Wheaton that was funny
and Wil Wheaton was like an sjw
that's how that's how crazy for left
there but gab for instance is on the Fed
averse okay meaning that if I create my
own server
Tim cast calm then I would say follow me
my handle is Tim at Tim cast calm and
then you would follow me and then you
would see whatever I post but no one
could ban me because you're basically
just going to my website so what it
basically does is it creates a Twitter
feed
but each person's tweet or post comes
from their own different different
servers that you that once it popped
once it's delivered to you hmm
so nobody can ban you if you're on a
node like GABA okay gab could say we're
banning messed up hmm but you know gab
wouldn't do that
however mastodons did bandgap they're
like if you're on our node you will not
see anyone from gab notice yeah you
can't do it hmm
so it's it's actually also a really
really good idea because then instead of
me saying you know follow me on Twitter
I'd say my my handle is at Tim cast and
then it doesn't matter what you use you
get it that I think is a path forward
that will that will really save us from
the the the mind you know brainwashing
indoctrination these are the kind of
conversations I like having what about
moving forward but I think you know why
I think 230 reform is the Magic Bullet
hmm if the Republicans sweep and this is
why it is and I can't believe I ever
since I'm like that's so important to
that they do I am willing to concede at
this point without crazy everything's
gotten this is the Democrats have made
me desperate and now maybe I am turning
to people I don't quite understand you
know crazy so now I talked about this
though the Republican Party hasn't
varied very often there's a little bit
left
yeah very they've moved quite far far as
additional Republicans if this stops
I'll give you the best example the
Democrats just voted to repeal civil
rights law yeah that's crazy that that
is that was like being punched in the in
the in the in the gut that eyes a lot
that's insane I can't I can't believe
that that has to stop now absolutely and
that means if I have to go to the
Republican Party that means I have to do
it
you know so we'll see how so we'll see
how things play out with trumpets
different story but very likely I don't
I don't know what's gonna happen in with
with congressional votes or whatever in
in in November so we'll see how that
plays out but if the Republicans win and
the first thing they do is just jam
section 230 reform in it's gonna happen
right now there's a big boycott against
Facebook they're trying to get Facebook
to bend bend the knee and ban more hate
speech and Facebook is slowly giving
what they want but no matter what
Facebook does they say more more more
yeah what would happen if a law was
passed
you cannot ban legal speech then the
advertisers would go to Zuckerberg and
stay we demand all the far-left
nonprofits every email they could send
would fall on deaf ears when Donald went
when Mark Zuckerberg would simply reply
all that it would be illegal yeah that
would be easy and they would say well
then we don't wanna advertise with you
I'm so sorry
it's the law yeah if you want your
advertisers on this platform you'll
recognize that we can't control the
speech that's federal law boom it is the
easiest out it will bolster the profits
of Google Facebook Twitter and all these
companies it will give them the easiest
excuse we want to help you or so angry
at Trump no but unfortunately that's the
law we have to allow these opinions yeah
and I'm talking about evil people saying
evil things one of the tricks the
far-left likes to do is saying see they
won't do throats on their platform no
that's bad that's illegal you posted a
threat they can go delete that was a
crime yeah if they have a good faith
belief that what you post it was illegal
they can remove it mm-hmm
now there will be over step there will
be Appeals sure and I think it's it's
will Chamberlain of human events whose
proposal is that access to social media
should be considered a human right and
that if you get banned you can
immediately go to court and get an
injunction filed to restore all of your
access if if this reform happens then
immediately you will see a real
conversation all of the silent majority
will not be scared to speak up anymore
well not all of them but a lot of them
you won't get banned you can say
whatever you want we need that back we
need thick skin we need 230 reform yeah
we need to save
I mean to bring him even if you step
back like comedy is dying comedy up
dying think about if Carlin was like the
last vestige of just saying whatever he
wanted think about not care if you were
able to go on Twitter and make all of
the jokes from South Park and Family Guy
without getting banned yeah right now
you can't 230 reform is maybe not the
most important thing I don't know but I
think it's extremely important because
it would reverse the flow of the
cultural stream yeah John Cleese said it
says something really interesting about
this I don't remember all of it man
there's there's a lot but it started
with if people can't control their
emotions they just they switch it to try
to control other people's behavior and
there's a lot more to that but it's
about having thick skin it's about
confronting yourself and you know useful
bring it back yeah and I love it imagine
if you go on some amazing idea and it's
nothing but grow a pair you whiny baby
cry keep crying and you're like you
can't say mean things to me that's
illegal
sorry it's not it's legal think about
all of listen listen oh people don't
realize doctor hearing what other people
think that is number one don't care what
other people think why is that why do
you care so much work on your own life
you'll get banned if you work on your
own life if because I just said that to
them right now I'm gonna get banned if
you ignore what other people think you
get banned
oh I don't ignore it I I'm watching
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you